we now would like to generalize our
concept of work to the motion of an
object that goes in more than one
dimension and so if we have our object
here and we're applying a force and the
object is moving and let's say the path
is a little bit more complicated so our
object a little bit later has moved and
we're going to call that the
displacement we now want to generalize
our concept to work to handle this type
of motion in more than one dimension in
order to do that we'll need a new
mathematical operation which we're going
to call the scalar product so what I'd
like to do first is define this in terms
of vectors and then we'll apply it to
the concept of work so suppose I have
two vectors a and another vector B and
they're separated by an angle theta and
in this case our theta we're going to
just take it between 0 and PI now I'd
like to talk about how much one vector
projects in the direction of the other
so if I call this the parallel component
of B then I wanted to find a quantity
which we're going to call the scalar
product of a dot B which is the
magnitude of a time's the amount of B
that is in the direction parallel to a
now from our geometric diagram you can
see that B parallel is equal to the
magnitude of B times cosine of theta now
remember theta is going from 0 to PI so
this quantity B parallel can both be
positive or negative if theta is between
0 and PI over 2 then in that range the
cosine goes from 1 to 0 and this
quantity B
will be greater or equal to zero be
parallel if theta is going from PI over
2 theta 2 pi then we have that B
parallel is less than or equal to 0 and
in particular at the value PI over 2 be
parallel 0 because when fade is PI over
2 the B vector is completely
perpendicular to a and this is what
we're going to define to be the scalar
product but geometrically we can also
look at let's draw our pictures again a
and B and now let's consider how much of
a is parallel to B so that's a parallel
and if this is the angle theta we see
that a parallel here and I'll write it
as a parallel is the magnitude of a
times cosine of theta and so I can also
define a dot B as equal to how much of a
is parallel to B times the magnitude of
B now in both of these instances because
B parallel is the magnitude of B cosine
theta and a pal is the magnitude of a
cosine theta what we're writing is is
that a dot B is the magnitude of a
cosine theta magnitude of B and now you
can see that this quantity is a parallel
and this quantity is B parallel and this
is our geometric definition of a dot
product now one thing that we want to
consider are two important rules for dot
products and they're the following that
if we take a vector and multiply a by a
quantity as
see here is a scalar quantity then this
is equal to C times a dot B now
geometrically this is very easy to see
because if we draw a and we draw B and
if I multiply a by a scalar and let's
make in this particular picture our
scalar bigger than 1 then the new vector
a is multiplied by C and it's C times a
and the scalar product is just see a dot
B is the magnitude of C a times how much
of B is parallel and when you multiply
this together you get C times a times B
parallel now C of a dot B is equal to C
times the magnitude of a times B
parallel and you can see that these two
expressions are equal so if you multiply
a dot product by a scalar it satisfies
this rule and there's one other crucial
rule that we'll need when we look at
vectors that if you take a vector a and
you add to it a vector B and you dot it
into a vector C then that's this is
vector addition and vector
multiplication this vector addition
distributes over vector multiplication
by a dot C plus B dot C so these two
facts are crucial to our development of
vectors and one thing that we can say is
we'll leave this as a little exercise
for you to prove this result you
is pretty straightforward vector
construction and to just give you a
little bit of a hint if we have a vector
a and another vector B and we have a
similar vector C then if I draw the
vector a dot B plus B and I want to take
a dot C so I have how much of a is
parallel to C and if I look at how much
of B is parallel to C then as part of
the exercise make sure that you can see
that how much of a plus B parallel to C
agrees to this distributive rule so
these are our definition of a scalar
product and the two key facts that we'll
need when we apply it in our example of
work